We put six drops of
lavender on this pad here.
And then we just turn it on.
And then there's a little heater
in here, an electric heater,
that causes the
lavender to vaporize.
And then it comes out of here.
I've been interested in horses
ever since I was a child.
I started riding when I was six.
And then I became interested
in science and research.
And then I happened to
meet a couple of people
who were doing equine therapy.
I became aware of how horses are
being used with people to help
reduce their stress levels.
So that really gave
me the inspiration
for doing more work
with horses and people.
I teach a course
at the University
of Arizona, Physiology
for Mind Body Interaction.
ISABELLE: One of the units that
we were learning specifically
talks about the amygdala.
And then we also learn
about the olfaction system
and how it has a direct
link to the amygdala.
And aroma therapy
was always something
that I was kind of interested in
and wanted to learn more about
and to see how it
works and understanding
how it might be able to impact
our stress response because
of the amygdala.
And from there we were able
to come up with an experiment
that we were both interested in.
The lavender physiologically
causes them to relax.
It stimulates what's called the
parasympathetic nervous system,
which then stimulates
the salivary glands
to produce saliva.
So licking and chewing
is a sign of relaxation.
Horses have an extremely
sensitive sense of smell.
And they are sensitive animals
because they are prey animals.
They evolved as prey animals.
They're always looking
around to make sure
that there's no danger.
That's why horses are a good
model for testing aroma therapy
because they're highly
sensitive and they
have a good sense of smell.